c'est un véritable gouttes de nerf à
seulement 15 jours d'inscrit un très
disputé
[Musique]
les ravisseurs réclament le départ
définitif de la présidente
ça risque d'être compliqué alors
j'espère que vous êtes pas en train de
me parler de votre album
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'on cherche pour l'instant on n'a pas
de nom pas d'adresse et pas de visage
non plus c'est sûrement pour cette
raison qui porte des cagoules
je sais que vous êtes évidemment
c'est pas une bavure policière hein
les rumeurs sont vraies je ressors un
nouvel album c'est pas un album que tu
as fait c'est un best of
tout le monde
je montre aux gens ce que je vaux
vraiment faut que je leur montre que je
suis un grand flic
qui peut encore les protéger
OK